well hello kitties are you looking for a
movie to add to your halloween horror
movie freight set
i believe i have just a thing here we go
tales from the crypt demon knight so
tales from the crypt demon knight came
out in 1995 i believe it was it was the
tales from the [ __ ] movie based off of
the tales from the crypt
tv show if you don't know what tales
from the crypt was think
outer limits with a halloween horror
edge to it granted outer limits
sometimes was that but tails from the
crypt
was always that hosted by the crypt
keeper cryptkeeper was my hero
cryptkeeper attitude cryptkeeper puns it
was one of those shows
i watched and my mom never knew i
watched i just had to be skillful of
knowing when it was on when she would or
would not be there and then watch tales
from the crypt one could say
in order to not get caught i had to be
very very
scareful but all right so demon knight
and the premise of demon knight
very simple william sadler is the good
guy he has a key a key that this demon
played by billy zane wants then william
sadler and a bunch of civilians are
holed up in this hotel and billy zane
and these demons that he summons from
the ground are trying to get in to get
that key so they have to survive
and escape and that's the night all
right so out the gate what i love about
this movie billy zayn it's one of those
movies with one of those roles you watch
you're like
why don't we see more billy zane now
he's completely amazing and steals the
show and tales from the [ __ ] demon
knight he was great and titanic where is
he and maybe he doesn't want to be in
the forefront maybe he just doesn't like
the spotlight
he gets consistent work but maybe just
like i don't need that [ __ ] what is he's
such a great actor and he was great in
demon knight i mean him being a demon he
has this
carefree snarky ass attitude i wouldn't
say carefree because
definitely he seems stressed out at the
fact that this guy
just won't give this key to him whole
dunk well then there [ __ ]
but the point is he just has a devilish
playful attitude in this movie and he's
just
such a dick when he does it there are a
couple scenes he just kind of reminds me
of
the evil version of the genie from
aladdin i'm not gonna
compare him to robin williams wit or
anything but he does have a couple times
where he's dressed one way you know he
has one costume and then he gives
someone a vision they're in a completely
different place
and then he's in that vision and he's
dressed a completely different way and
he has a completely different attitude
you can just tell billy zane was having
so much fun in this role and he was just
owning it there's actually a
surprisingly big
cast not just william sadler i'm talking
thomas hayden church
jada pinkett the legendary dick miller
you might know from
any of those movies you enjoyed from the
80s or your childhood
some of the visual effects do look dated
i'm talking the cgi effects you know the
ones
done on computers for some odd reason
i'm like that looks like 1985 not
necessarily 1995. i get the movie
didn't have a huge budget though so
there is that besides it's an old horror
movie what is
old horror movie if it doesn't have
dated visual effects
part of the charm really the special
effects the practical effects i think
those are great the demons growing out
of the ground the creature designs
they look like ghoulish goblin-like
demons but the point is when it comes to
bloody messy gory [ __ ] refuse
just what i like in a movie like this
this movie does have it
it looks pretty disgusting so i enjoyed
that i enjoyed the practical effects
i will say and i'll say it here and i
mean this phrase as a compliment which
is funny because usually when i say this
phrase i mean it as a negative
and anyone out there who says this
phrase for this movie and you mean it as
a negative i completely understand
because when i do say this phrase i
usually mean it as a negative
but in this case i mean it as a positive
tales from the crypt demon knight
feels like a two-hour episode of tales
from the crypt
in terms of tone and execution
this does feel like a two-hour episode
of tales from the crypt
and i gotta say that's probably what
makes it work for me right down to the
crypt keeper having the intro and the
outro say in the entire story you just
feel like they
knew it was the tales from the crypt
movie but you had to keep that tales
from the crypt tv show flavor
and they did now does this mean you have
to enjoy the tales from the crypt show
in order to enjoy demon knight
i don't know i have to think there's
probably a causality there or at the
very least
if you like demon knight and you've
never seen the tales from the crypt tv
show
i imagine you will probably like the
tales from the crypt tv show and that's
many more hours of ghoulish
entertainment that you can enjoy so
enjoy and you're welcome the one thing i
wish this movie
gave me was more billy zane i get it you
want to leave the audience wanting more
but in a world where we don't have a
sequel to demon knight
leave the audience wanting more without
giving them more later just
it kind of feels a little empty in
hindsight could have gone for a couple
more scenes with billy zane i just what
can i say i like my fun demon [ __ ]
having fun on screen that's completely
what he is and what he did like i said
in the beginning of this video
if you want to have a halloween movie
binge
and you want a pretty fun one yet
ridiculous one but one that owns what it
is
tales from the crypt demon night it's a
great time no alcohol required you know
now that i'm talking about it i do want
to see a resurgence of tales from the
crypt i would love this show to come
back
or for there to be another tales from
the crypt movie don't let it die with
bordello of blood i think tails from the
crypt has more to offer i think
fans would eat it up i would all right
so tales from the crypt demon knight
have you seen it what
do you think about it do you have fun
with it is it too cheesy for your taste
did you
enjoy tales from the crypt the tv show
back in the day do you enjoy it now
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you